hey 42 here I take you for better for
worse for richer for poorer in sickness
and in health to love and to cherish
till death us do part or not what if
death wasn't the end of marriage well
for hundreds of French people every year
it isn't neck raga me is the act of
marrying the debt it's been legal to
marry the deceased in France since 1959
and every year in France
hundreds of ceremonies are held to marry
an individual with a deceased
significant other whilst not as common
posthumous marriages are also practiced
in the US Germany Sudan Thailand China
South Africa and South Korea now it's
easy to see why people who have
tragically lost their soulmate would
want to do this
it's a beautiful symbolic gesture very
odd but beautiful book guys what is
quite the opposite happens what if you
get sick of your wife and I don't mean
like that time when you have to take a
sabbatical in the garden shed two hours
I'm talking about actually selling your
wife now before you go and list your
beloved on eBay
just hold on a minute because it's a
little more complicated than that not to
mention illegal
and you'll just end up with a slap to
the face and a few more hours in the
shed
wife selling is not just an urban myth
it's a very real part of global history
particularly in Old England all limit is
frowned upon today and rightfully so
throughout periods in history why
selling was incredibly popular so then
let's go shopping it's a 19th century
market in Britain a Victorian era
english market was a feast for the
senses the smell of freshly roasted
Holland coffee beans tousled with the
ghastly sense of animal and even human
sewage running down the streets the
sound of cattle and squealing pigs
pervades the air as did the chatter from
the crowd brimming with vagabond thieves
the wealthy and they're not so wealthy
all of whom had to compete with
street hawkers selling their once most
prized possession their wife will roll
up she's hard-working deceptively strong
and younger than she looks
only five shillings a real bargain folks
men selling their wives was a common
sight at markets in Britain beginning in
the late 17th century this common
practice continued all the way until the
early 20th century the first cause of
divorce was established in England in
1857 before this it was very costly and
difficult to detangle oneself from their
wife if a man wanted rid of the wife or
vice-versa
the man would have to pay the
present-day equivalent of 15,000 pounds
for a private act of parliament and you
had to obtain the blessing of the church
which was about as easy as splitting an
Aston with a sledgehammer so
unsurprisingly poorer members of society
especially those who had large debts
would look to sell their wives instead
why selling was particularly popular in
the West Midlands of England but
Yorkshire held the crown with the most
number of wife sales between 1760 and
1880 and the only place in the world
where a man could probably still trade
his wife for a pie today men would sell
their wives usually to pay taxes they
otherwise couldn't afford or to settle
gambling debts or simply to buy food in
times of famine now obviously being sold
as a chattel isn't exactly nice but more
often than not the decision wasn't
forced upon the wife as a lot of the
time it will be the woman's idea to be
sold in the first place if a marriage
went sour and the couple were no longer
happy together it often made more sense
for the woman to be sold and at least
she could be with somebody else rather
than continue their deeply unhappy
relationship even if she didn't see any
of the profits on her sale regular
divorce was just financially out of the
question for the vast majority of people
so the decision has been made
the wife's gotta go but how exactly does
a man go about selling
person his own wife nonetheless well
there was actually a semi-official
system for doing so and it was
surprisingly simple the man would take
his wife to the market with a halter
around her neck just as he would one of
his animals shocking I know he would
then have to pay a small market tile
which would allow him to sell goods at
the market that day the rest was simply
a massive good sales chatter he would
parade his missus around on a leash
bellowing her benefit some features from
the top of his lungs and when he had
gathered a crowd of her few interested
punters the auction would begin auctions
usually started up a few pence but could
rise all the way up to a pound yes a
pound depending on how desirable the
auctioneers fair lady was now there may
still be smaller than equality issues in
society today but it's fair to say we've
come a long long way from the days when
you could tie your wife up like a pig
take her to market and flog her for a
pound
however women weren't simply offered to
the highest bidder
she had the option to veto offers as her
will if she didn't like the look or
smell of the gentleman in question once
a winning bidder had been found the
exchange would take place which was
basically a mini marriage ceremony on
the street or often in the port right
there and then before the marriage act
of 1753 in England the marriage did not
require a formal ceremony with a vicar
marriage was no more than an agreement
between two people even after the
marriage I came into effect these quick
street marriages still took place what
the church simply refused to recognize
the couple's union but nothing stopped
people astonishingly money wasn't the
only commodity exchange for a man's wife
here's an shewill snippet from the world
newspaper on November the 12th 1790 a
man at nymphal stocks in Sussex lost
weight sold his wife to another man of
the same place for our--for time to gin
the purchase of being in liquor at the
time the bargain was concluded the
selarón ordered I should not complain of
any unfair advantage having been taken
event took his dear spouse Tibetan bored
until the next morning when the buyer
attended in claimed his lady he was
delivered by the husband in due form
having got also around the neck and two
witnesses present the woman appeared
overjoyed at the change nor did the man
seem less happy out there Lots now he
didn't understand any of that amongst
all his wife for half a bottle of gin
she was overjoyed and he can care less
after an exchange there now ex-husband
handed over a toll ticket basically a
receipt to the new husband as a proof of
sale the active wife selling was slowly
phased out until it became completely
unheard of by the mid 20th century as
divorce courts became more prevalent and
cheaper well in England at least however
wife selling remained a thing for many
years in a few other countries even if
most of the time it was illegal today
though there was only one remaining
country that commonly practices why
selling India in rural India
particularly in a region known as bungle
camp lifes rests on that year's harvest
if the harvest is poor then a famine is
guaranteed in times of desperation and
starvation
many families turn to the local
Passarella a wealthy man who lends money
the local pastor wallah will loan
farmers money but the loans come with
extremely high interest rates and if the
years ahead are also drought filled and
lead to poor harvests then the farmers
may not be able to sell crops and pay
off the expensive loan in such
situations they have both one option
sell their wife the farmer will either
sell his wife to another man and use the
funds to pay off the Passarella or more
often than not the Passarella will
themself take ownership of the man's
wife and keep her as payment forcing her
to live with him for as long as the debt
to remains unpaid even if that is
forever
what's even more sickening is that if
the pastor one
leave that the farmer's wife isn't
valuable enough to settle the debt in
full then they may take the farmers
children also sadly this part of India
is renowned for its inhumane treatment
of women but what about in the Western
world has there been any records of
wives selling in the modern day well
unbelievably yes and it takes us back to
the historic home of wife selling yoga
in 2016 a man from Wakefield Yorkshire
lifted his one term wife on ebay after a
long day at work the 33 year old man
returned home to be subjected to his
wide moaning at him to which he replied
right I'm going to put you up for sale
the listing was simply titled used wife
the description included the following
good points bodywork and paint work
still in decent shape and has some
skills in the kitchen bad points often
makes this no you that cannot be
silenced unless you order brand new
shiny parts of metal and offers welcome
may consider a past exchange for a
younger model the auction reached 65
thousand pounds before it was removed by
eBay thankfully it was just a joke and
the couple are still happily together
after he bought so many many shiny
things to say sorry thanks for watching
[Music]
you